tout ce qu'ils veulent finalement vers
une chasse est vive et select ou à la
kiné cash in la guerre animals
ces musulmans qu'on appelle des rohingya
ne peuvent retourner dans leur pays
le myanmar l'ex birmanie ils sont
persécutés et exterminer là bas par les
bouddhistes l'or mais on va tenter de
montrer notre nation il est toujours
éliminé toujours le mieux les mini show
fils mohamed et sa femme sont arrivés à
québec en novembre 2008
non je vais aller le voir il me donnait
déborder le manteau et des pantalons le
chapeau les gars polonais de nourriture
même je les connais même pas ben vous
êtes en plus vous n'êtes pas musulman
il n'y a pas de discrimination albeau
autres ce jeune père de famille était
bouleversée de voir des étrangers
le traité comme un humain dans les camps
de réfugiés au bangladesh
ils étaient traités comme des bêtes en
cage et dans sa birmanie natale les
musulmans comme lui n'ont aucun droit et
même là pas le doigt dans la seconde il
ne sait pas l'ipo les fans il n'y a pas
deux doigts de marié polli folie's ont
l'amour de belleval et nous donne pas
par messiaen pour faire quelque chose
pour les business et pour les bouviers
pour le travail et pour le fait porter
toutes les choses arrêté pour nous
rafik mohamed avait 15 ans quand lui et
sa famille ont fui les massacres de 1991
qui ont poussé 250000 euros nghia sur
les routes de l'exil
il ya beaucoup d'étudiants est mort et
dans notre pays c'est à cette époque que
j'ai fait une bêtise étudiants qui fait
aussi un conseil et audit et de patrick
étudiants professeurs contre le gros lot
do with many et ils ont attrapé
beaucoup de mouvements des trous et
beaucoup de villages des poulets
l'héroïne biovive pourtant depuis des
siècles dans ce petit coin de paradis
l'arakan était un royaume indépendant
jusqu'à l'invasion des birmans voisins
en 1754
elle devient ensuite une simple province
de l'empiré colonial britannique en asie
qui comprend l'inde et la birmanie
et après ils donnaient là notre pays
avec birmanie est la troupe est finie la
persécution centenaire des musulmans
prendre les allures de génocide quand la
junte militaire révoque leur citoyenneté
en 1982 l'héroïne bien perdre
tranquillement leur emploi
le père de sophie un fonctionnaire de
l'état et forcé à la retraite à l'âge de
50 ans mon père l'avait dit pas d'accord
aux hôtels on dénonce doit pas l'être
cette parce qu'ils étaient mis en garde
peu les emplois des musulmans c'est
quand le père de sophie va défendre sa
cause au palais de justice on
l'empêchent de traverser une rue les
déplacements sont désormais interdits
horonya sans permission
et puis on les dépouilles de tous leurs
avoirs la voiture le bateau le taire
quand leur maison est incendié les
mohamed prennent la fuite avec huit
enfants dont un bébé donne on avait eu
aimons mais pareil
il avait du snow autres il y avait bien
deux derniers nous autres parce que son
taux de voler la maison c'est pas juste
ma maison par exemple ça a été ça a été
mille maisons sans me lemaire qui était
voulu leur aide à penser aux autres ils
font des choses comme ça
en 2012 les bouddhistes intensifie les
violences contre la minorité musulmane
il n'est plus possible pour un rohingya
de vivre dans un village
ils sont presque tous confinés dans des
camps qui ressemble à des prises
c'est très très difficile pour eux de
vives
en birmanie même aller chercher de l'eau
aller chercher de l'eau c'est difficile
est-ce qu'ils ont peur de sortir de
l'enceinte du camp ils ont pardon ils
ont été terrorisés ils ont vécu des
blessures graves ils ont vu des gens ce
phare torturé alors sait déjà qu'ils
sont en état de choc aussi micheline
lévesque a travaillé plusieurs années en
birmanie elle y a été interdit de séjour
après avoir rencontré en scène sushi
l'opposante au régime militaire
emprisonné chez elle pendant 20 ans élue
en 2012
les prix nobel de la paix n'a pas pris
la défense des rohingya à le déçu
plusieurs personnes les gens disaient
mais elle va parler ouvertement
mais c'est une politicienne les
élections arrivent bientôt
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose qui
est qui et populaires en birmanie alors
elle est très prudente
le président a dit clairement que la
seule solution des violences dans l'état
d'arakan c'était l'expulsion des roms
jean l'expulsion ou la fuite pour éviter
les massacres depuis le 31 mars
depuis que les cartes d'identité des
rohingya ont été invalidés des dizaines
de milliers ont embarqué dans des
bateaux de fortune
ce comme des fantômes des apatrides qui
sont pas reconnus à nulle part qui se
promènent en mer
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est vif moi je
veux une vie de luxe ici aux autres moi
j'étais là quand vous autres aux autres
bulbes en gare avec la vidange et
toujours qui l'habille risques et aux
jeunes les rohingya réfugiés à québec 5
en permanence pour leurs parents laissés
derrière ils ne comprennent pas
l'indifférence de la communauté
internationale
il ya des femmes qui dans le cinq il
coupe comme ça il met des enfants comme
ça ils font des cuissons
mon pc ça me quitter nîmes aurillac
nouvelle décision
on attend toujours la droit on attend
toujours une lieu la monde qui va qui va
faire justice pour les autres par la
tente au mieux